welcome and to this video back door 13
ahead and recently right what was this
it was a Ben Oni if i'm not mistaken
we're so i stumbled into a bad position
out of this ok let's do a bit more let's
do it in a bit more solid fashion and go
for bogo might have three Jack now night
BTW to a snorer here 2294 is not not so
convincing quindi 294 Oh Ricky does he
loves that kind Queen before check it's
a bit awkward for my turn check
d for Hank so night d 2 nite device is
really bad so he has to do this now I'm
grabbing upon but it's not a it's not a
clean pawn why it has some compensation
it's not considered to be sufficient but
it is some compensation let's see and I
don't really know how black usually
continues him maybe I can do this okay
he can actually trade this this might be
right but people are often reluctant to
trade when they have material down okay
now i can take the form not sure that I
want five i mean if i take tes he takes
you seven that looks really awkward on
the other hand i will take be too that's
really a lot of material
I mean I'm perfectly aware that I'm
losing one point back but i have to pay
so that was my my rationale there but
not sure if it was a good one
maybe f6 is actually a move takes Queen
cheeks sharpie seven then look a seven
chat it's not super comfortable here
admittedly I'm not the kind of person
who normally just grabs material and
then tries to justify the problem
somehow I'll get get out of this I get
out of Harry positions when you have
grabbed material let's say there are
certainly players some were better in
those scenarios I think maybe a form
looks weakening but see I am keeping the
pawn is probably a good idea how do i
canna somehow get rid of this queen rook
a 64 queen bee six check hmm he has
rupee one down not sure that this ever
is going to help I mean 11 idea might be
Roxie six actually and some in some
situations like Bishop c6 beat eggs by
getting Bishop a6c 45 those kind of
ideas that actually wouldn't be too bad
okay I have to check their check it can
take it can take a for you Jim
it should be said Bishop e7 is not not
not a problem I mean this is three
points now
free porn seems a bit much if it takes
on b7 I mean I can take Luke cheeks and
at least Queen c6 returning yet another
porn but I'm still keeping one I really
just took everything here yeah that's
also in okay I cannot take with the rook
anyway so let's do this
I think I'm okay yeah I mean he has some
this activity but three points and I
have this rook c6 resource that I really
like f5 is interesting now hmm yeah
should be five after a five-year 75 I
wonder d 5 is rubbish right yeah this
rubbish
oh ok Bishop she gonna need six sorry
don't see a good move han Queen Queen
some or 2d six maybe ok I can do that
for Queen d6 tried to get rid of the
Queen hunt on c7 f is six sorry fe 6d is
six Bishop d7 hi Brooke a seven at least
for trades ok she wants to check their
icy but still it's just a check
k Queen then to h6 I see check I go look
b6 takes takes check their queen age six
at the end I'm having a counter maid so
let's do this Wow yeah this is why I
normally don't grep pawn so it's all so
ready lip then they have to get into
this defensive mode I mean age six queen
bee one year here I can shake maybe but
Queen age six is a big one for made time
morning you have to go back then for
Queenie seven ultimately but i still
have my pawns i have have taken
everything and it's not it's not
apparent what he's doing okay wait wait
wait wait probably here no II five I
guess I should Bishop g5 is not really
threatening anything
I don't I don't see a threat ham
and well I've got four passed pawns him
Queen g7 maybe Queen g7 queen age five
ok it's not threatening anyway I think
so I just pushed stuff ok ok now I can
do that the Queen age five is actually
out of out of ideas g5 just pawn takes
Queen chicks not on what I can take with
a pond is firing every bullet on my time
actually just trying to win on time
checkmate ok we yeah this was tough I
just grabbed everything inside and yeah
played this kind of show me chess show
me how you kill me after I grabbed
everything I mean he had an excellent
position for sure which at least
compensated for the pawns but I really
after I got the a porn I'm not so
convinced really f6f for a six computer
gives me a slight edge it says I get
Quinn b6 and now amazing and after that
i'm clearly better yeah yeah to be
honest I was thinking I should be better
here I know I mean three pawns if he's
not killing me immediately this this
will win and I don't I don't see how he
kills me I mean it looks really bad but
he cannot take here for example uk7 as
is a really really bad pin sure and this
looked like a good try but we can take
it six that would have been much better
the computer gives me five as usual
totally fearless Jim this check it looks
a bit scary but to be us when you once
you look at it he doesn't even have I
was kind of hallucinating queen to d6
but that's of course nonsense i just
take sorry my mouse again ah come on
yeah yeah i take it only six but I went
I went here and this after day he has to
take as a compliment I actually just
wanted to recapture why is it not
working Ruby to be one with equality no
now with an advantage for white what is
the idea Rock the aid or look D 4G 4G
for maybe the engine is giving h5 if you
have to play h5 something is seriously
wrong ok maybe that was a moment way
could have punished my magritte I have
to go e 5 and probably but but I think
after that it should be ok it went back
up here check yeah and she cannot go
here because this is running a giant
counter maid so this
yeah and this is just this is now ok
absolutely solid defense and the pawns
pawns promote there are very difficult
way to player grabbing everything and
trying to defend but sometimes it works
thanks for watching